well it's no spider-man 3 but it sure is
the conjuring 3. the devil made me
do it uh we got a final trailer here
for uh this movie and also it's coming
out hbo
max being released in the theaters this
weekend it's not a promo
for them that i'm doing i'm just letting
you guys know subscribe because it's
coming out hbo max though
we will be doing a movie reaction to it
so guys subscribe and click that
notification bell
to get notified when our reaction for
that movie is up hopefully we enjoy it
the mirror mix things
i'm hearing that at least the warrens
are good
yes i actually kind of listened to both
chris stuckman and jeremy johns this
morning on their reviews
i normally don't listen to reviews
before i watch a movie
i like her the first like two minutes of
both and
it was like wow you guys got very
different reviews
so yeah all right yeah that's good i'm
excited for that and in situations like
that where i go
cool all right yeah i don't know how to
feel i don't know how i didn't come out
feeling either
yeah that's exciting to me all right
let's see what's in store
the court accepts the existence of god
every time a witness swears to tell the
truth
i think it's about time to accept the
existence of the devil
okay
we think this family was cursed
and saying he was possessed by demons
[Music]
i got chills yeah
gold standard wow where's the gold stand
straight out of exorcist that shot
oh no oh
well done shot yeah that was a really
well done shot they do love those
like shadow wipes into demon face
oh man ed himself is caught in the
vision traps dude he needs to go into
the further and rescue lorraine
this movie looks like the exorcism of
emily rose meets the exorcist meets
texas chainsaw massacre the first 10
minutes
yeah some amityville horror just you
know because
yeah because warren's i don't know man
you know like
i had a i really like the tone of this
trailer and i like the atmosphere of it
a hell of a lot too
from everything i've been hearing which
is not a lot
the trailers are really making it look
like that it's a
like a you know courtroom case trial
kind of like
exorcism of emily rose but it's not
really heavily
dealing with that as much as the
trailers might lead you to
believe but it is very ed on the rain
warren
focused which the trailers don't really
make me feel like it is
either so i'm kind of i am very curious
to know
how i'll walk out of this movie
ultimately feeling if like oh yeah i
agree with this critic more than this
critic yeah yeah and i was you just got
to be honest by the time it's all said
and done because right now i think it
looks pretty chill and it looks it looks
spooky and
it looks like a conjuring
yeah yeah yeah and i get some of what
i've heard like i was listening to campy
the other day and he said part of what
he thought about this was that the
trailers haven't been as grabby as the
previous movies ones there's
it's flashy and i can agree with that
but i think what this has that gives me
hope for it is you know the previous
conjuring films all had a strong sense
of the ensemble of characters who are
really being affected by
what's going on with this you know
possession or haunting or poltergeist or
whatever it is
even though yeah this isn't really
giving me a sense for the personal
investment of ed and lorraine beyond
that they were called in to help deal
with this
it looks like it's going to maintain
that sense of like you're really going
to be
in at least somewhat the lives of the
characters being affected and
then you know that will make all of
these horror elements you know scary
yeah because there are a lot of things
in this trailer like where the creepy
smile guy comes up even that wipe in the
hall which is like
it's it's well done but you know it's
the kind of scare i'm used to seeing
from the conjuring and so i feel like
it's those character beats that help
elevate it maybe sync something like
this director's previous conjuring
chapter which was the curse of lagurona
which sort of didn't have that stuff as
much i really get the
impression that it's not as terrifying
as the other ones just because remember
the first two conjuring trailers are
pretty damn scary
and these have been like creepy and
unnerving but like you said
a little used to kind of what we've been
getting from here the thing that makes
this look
a little bit different than the other
ones is i mean other than of course the
fact it's not a haunted home and all
that and it's not solely focused on a
family that they're protecting
that's kind of it is that and the other
ones are protecting a family so
the trailers spooks often seem to rely
on them having to protect the family
that was in danger
where it really looks like the danger
the threat
is directly aimed at ed and lorraine
warren in this one which feels very
different i haven't heard anyone
say that i guess i'm getting from just
the trailers alone
well in the previous movies have done
that too like the second movie
especially
built that whole thing up with the nun
and lorraine you know facing off with
her and being targeted by her and things
like that and
it's closer towards like the last half
of the defense like the trailers
i'm saying the chosen like the chosen i
remember with the second one that really
focused on like crosses turning upside
down a little girl in the room being
surrounded by that you know like
especially the trailers here yeah yeah
but here it's uh
it's like wow they they look like
they're in a lot of trouble apparently
yeah they're gonna jump down a cliff to
save her and everything yeah
yeah yeah and normally it i mean i might
just be remembering this incorrectly
because i've only seen those other ones
once
i always recall the rain is the one
who's kind of in the vision traps
and ed is is the one who's like lorraine
lorraine
i need to either save you or interpret
what you're you know going through for
other people
but uh but it looked like an especially
in that that final spook moment that it
was uh ed who was really thrusted into
here too
one thing i've heard about this movie is
it definitely hones in on the demonic
and satanic aspects of the case and so i
feel like that's something you can't
necessarily communicate
broadly in a trailer that's supposed to
appeal to a lot of people but you can
get pretty heavy with in a in a movie
like this you know
and it's pretty unnerving you know
subject matter when you get into like
actual
demonic possession i think it's going to
be undercut by the fact
that it's he's going to go
full on horror demon trophy
yeah and you're not going to believe any
of the like oh the trial
really was influenced by a demon because
i don't think i don't think they're
going to have but sell me on that one
bit
the way how exorcism emily rose did that
to me was like maybe it was but yeah
this one i'm like nah it's just a hobby
it's going to be absolutely gonna be the
hollywood movie it's just gonna feel
like that
anyway guys the conjuring the devil made
me do it are you excited for this movie
at all are you tired of this franchise
are you still looking forward to it if
you like the hype for this one just
hasn't been as big leave your thoughts
down below subscribe
click that notification bell hit that
like button and last but not least
i want to shout out today christopher
wham-off because if there's anyone
who would unnecessarily thrust
themselves
into removing a demon out of a
soul-possessed
it would be chris wham-off he would rise
to the occasion
no matter what he loves helping people
even if he's not skilled or
knows any of the right biblical phrases
to do he would hop in there fully
confident
and then he would transfer the soul the
demon into the man who's been blowing
leaves the second we hit record
out here i'm sick of it it's like they
time it specifically to interrupt
the audio of the video when the audio of
the video itself is
already just reasonably okay and then
they just
make it worse so chris do your duty help
out that demon
boy and transferred into that man out
there damn this man so he can go to
van nuys california instead thank you so
much chris for being part of our patreon
[Music]
page